the Trump camp decides to attack the
Muller investigation in a new way
the media continue to play into Trump's
hands on ms-13 and we check the mailbag
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
man this has been a busy news week and
there's a lot to get to today I do want
to remind you that we will be talking
doing this show in August in Dallas and
Phoenix and if you're you've been
hearing me talk to premium subscribers
all week about these to live podcasts
that were doing well today at 10 a 10
a.m. local time
tickets finally go on sale for the
general public so you don't have to be
subscriber now you can buy the tickets
we've sold almost half of each event
just in the pre-sale so general
admission tickets and VIP packages are
gonna go really really fast be sure to
check out daily wired.com slash events
for tickets and additional information
again these tickets are going incredibly
fast my guess is that they will be sold
out within the next couple of days so
you're gonna want to buy now and at 10
a.m. they go on sale so it's a beautiful
time to get ready and if you still want
to get those presale tickets you have
like an hour and a half left to do it
right here so you can do that as well
okay before I get into the news of the
day and there's plenty of news of the
day first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at Dollar Shave Club so
Dollar Shave Club delivers everything
you need to look feel and smell your
best they have a product for everything
you need to get ready in the bathroom
you know there's there's the they have
the the Carver shave butter which goes
on clear so that when you actually shave
you're not cutting yourself they have
the the body wash they have the shampoo
they have the whole deal everything you
need Dollar Shave Club can provide it
again shampoo conditioner body wash
toothpaste hair gel
even a but wife that will leave you
feeling absolutely tingly clean I'm a
fan of their calming body cleanser it
actually smells really good and all of
your Dollar Shave Club products are made
with top-shelf ingredients that won't
break your budget and you will feel the
difference here is a great way to try a
bunch of these products and you just try
them for five bucks you can get their
daily essentials starter set it comes
with body cleanser one white travel
these they're amazing butt wipes then
world-famous shea butter and their best
razor the six blade executive and then
you keep the blades coming for a few
bucks more every month so you don't have
to worry about running out to the store
because you have only a bunch of dull
blades add in shampoo toothpaste
anything else you need for the bathroom
this also allows you to avoid going to
the drugstore at all so that your
significant other cannot pile you up
with other things you need to buy at the
drugstore just avoid it instead go to
dollarshaveclub.com slash been
dollarshaveclub.com slash pen when you
do that you get that special deal for
five bucks you get their daily
essentials starter kit
dollarshaveclub.com slash pen use that
slash pen so they know that we sent you
okay so we begin today with the latest
on the Muller investigation so there's
this theory that is going around on the
right and it's very hard
he's out exactly what people are
accusing various agencies of the stories
gotten so convoluted and so confused by
this point it's kind of hard to follow
the timeline as to what happened when
when the Muller investigation began when
the Trump Russia investigation began
when George papadopolis was meeting with
whom and when Trump jr. was meeting with
what and what the hell is going on so
we're going to try and tease out some of
that today and I have to say I think
that there are a lot of people who are
on the right who are falling for the
line that the FBI was deeply corrupt
before the election and I'm not seeing
the evidence that the FBI was acting a
deeply corrupt fashion with regard to
the Trump campaign before the election
happened I think a bunch of things can
be true ones and I think here here all
the things that can be tore ones one I
don't think there was collusion between
Trump and Russia I do not think that the
Trump campaign was actively working with
the Russians in order to shape the
election or in order Elyse emails from
Hillary Clinton via WikiLeaks or any of
that sort of thing I don't think there's
any evidence of that whatsoever - it is
true that there is willingness to
collude on the part of some members of
the Trump team that's pretty obvious at
this point Donald Trump jr. had a
meeting at Trump Tower with Natalia
Veselin skaia who was a Russian cutout
who was apparently going to give him
according to Rob Goldstone a former
Trump publicist was going to give the
Trump campaign a bunch of material on
Hillary Clinton that material never
materialized but vessel Mitch guy did
meet at Trump Tower with Donald Trump
jr. and then Trump jr. released as you
recall on Twitter a bunch of emails
saying that between him and Goldstone
talking about how he was excited that
the Russians wanted to back his dad in
the presidential campaign now
willingness to clewd is not actually a
crime and being willing to do something
isn't a crime if I'm willing to rob a
bank that is not the same thing as me
taking an active step toward the robbing
of the bank which is what conspiracy
would actually involve and even then
conspiracy is a little bit difficult to
prove it's a notoriously difficult crime
to prove in court okay that's not what
was happening here what happened here
was willingness not quite the same thing
so point number one there's no evidence
of collusion point number two there's
pretty good evidence of willingness to
collude by Donald Trump jr. and also by
George papadopolis who is this low-level
foreign policy aide to the Trump
campaign who all the way back in I
believe it was April of 2016 had a
meeting with a professor in London who's
actually from Malta I guess and was
associated with the Russian government
and had said to George papadopolis
that the Russians had access to Hillary
Clinton's emails so that doesn't mean
the emails past him the Papadopoulos was
willing to hear about it and then he
apparently bragged about it within the
hearing of the the Australian ambassador
who passed that information along to the
FBI which initiated part of the
investigation against George papadopolis
and attempts to get into the Trump
campaigns business okay so those two
things again no collusion willingness to
collude point number three if there was
willingness to collude and there was
good evidence that there are a bunch of
people in the Trump campaign who are at
the very least kind of dirty right paw
Amana Ford who is the Trump campaign
chair he's a dirty dude who was involved
with the Ukrainian government when it
was basically a Vladimir Putin front
group
you know Paul Manafort was involved
Connor page had been suspected of being
a Russian spy for a long time George
papadopolis as I just mentioned from
junior as I just mentioned it would have
been remiss for the FBI not to actually
check this stuff out because again
reverse the names if it weren't Donald
Trump we were talking about her but
Hillary Clinton everybody on the right
would have said how could the FBI not
have gone further in their investigation
into Hillary Clinton if it been Chelsea
Clinton meeting with Natalya vessel in
the sky had to find turn on Trump we'd
all be like whoa whoa hold up now we're
saying what and the FBI didn't
investigate so the FBI's investigation
could have been totally proper point
number four okay that all of these can
be true at the same time point number
four it is also true that all of the
leaks of this information post-election
are scurrilous and those are corrupt
okay leaking out information that does
not have confirmation leaking out
information in an attempt to implicate
the Trump campaign for stuff it didn't
do all of that is corrupt stuff
from Obama holdovers a lot of that
started happening immediately after the
election it passed all the way through
up until February in March of 2017 when
Trump was forced to fire Michael Flynn
all of that stuff I think is corrupt so
if there's corruption inside the FBI and
the CIA that corruption manifested
itself not in the investigation itself
it manifested itself in the leaks of the
investigation okay so today the big
story that is being pushed by folks on
the right is that it was the
investigation itself the stuff before
the election that was a real problem on
the part of the FBI so Andrea Mandy
McCarthy a friend of mine and a very
good lawyer he makes the case over at
National Review and here's what he
writes he says the youngins may not
believe it but back
for it was known as classic rock you
couldn't play a crossfire hurricane on
Spotify you had to spin it fittingly
that is exactly what the New York Times
has done in Wednesday's blockbuster
report on the origins of the Trump
Russia probe which was called crossfire
hurricane the quick take on the 4,100
word opus is that the grey lady buried
the lede fair enough you have to dig
pretty deep to find the FBI ran at least
one government informant against the
Trump campaign and to note that The
Times learned this because current and
former officials leaked to reporters the
same classified information about which
days ago the Justice Department's creat
shrieked extortion when Congress asked
for it so Congress has asked for all the
material as to what sort of spying
activities were going on with regard to
the Trump campaign and the Justice
Department has said no we're not going
to turn all of that over because it
would implicate an informant it would
put his life at risk for example and so
McCarthy saying well then why are you
leaking all that stuff to the press
about what the informant knew and who
kind of information about who he was
sort of that's a fair point by McCarthy
then he gets to the point that I don't
think his quite as good
he says that's not even the most
important of the Buried leads but the
time story makes explicit with studious
understatement is that the Obama
administration used its
counterintelligence powers to
investigate the opposition party's
presidential campaign there is no
criminal predicates to justify an
investigation of any Trump campaign
official so the FBI did not open a
criminal investigation instead the
bureau opened a counterintelligence
investigation and hoped that evidence of
crimes committed by Trump officials
would emerge but it is an abuse of power
to use counterintelligence powers
including spying and electronic
surveillance to conduct what is actually
a criminal investigation okay well first
of all it depends how they were using
these these counterintelligence measures
you'd have to make the case that what
the FBI was doing was actually illegal
unless they have for example a criminal
warrant and I'm not seeing any evidence
of that so one of the accusations that
the New York Times makes is that the FBI
had an informant inside the Trump
campaign well that informant could have
been somebody who's working for the
Trump campaign and went to the FBI it
could have been somebody the FBI
approached to go and talk to the Trump
campaign it is not illegal for the FBI
to do this this sort of stuff happens
regularly in all sorts of Investigations
at Brad Heath who is an investigative
reporter for USA Today who covers law
and justice he says I'm puzzled by the
argument that the use of an informant
tainted investigation informants are
ridiculously common part of law
enforcement investigations often at a
very early stage
the FBI's domestic operations guide
authorizes agents to use informants even
when they're conducting assessments
which don't require the
to a predicate of a formal investigation
there are lots of reasons to be
skeptical how the government uses
informants one ATF informant testified
that to get targets for a sting he
basically went up to people on the
street and asked if they wanted to do
drug robberies there were guys in
Atlanta who are paying other people for
information so they could proffer it to
the feds to get a sentence reduction
courts have it more or less said that
none of this is a valid basis to get a
case thrown out
so even when informants are super
sketchy you can't get a case thrown out
there's also not a clear line at least
not in law according brad heath that
separates what techniques are okay and
investigations of politicians compared
to say drug dealers and use the
informants in those cases to the uranium
one case had an informant the senator
menendez case had an informant but if
using an informant does taint an
investigation argues Brad Heath to the
point is Giuliani suggested that it
might have to be shut down that would
implicate a lot of federal cases and
again even with counterintelligence it's
not clear to me that a
counterintelligence investigation can't
use an informant in order to garner more
information so in other words if this
was not initiated for for stupid reasons
if this was initiated because there's a
piece of intelligence that went to the
FBI that George papadopolis had been
meeting with a guy who was offering him
all sorts of information from Russia and
the mission investigation and there was
an informant I still am not sure why
this is suddenly such a terrible thing
now a lot of this is being used to to
say that Trump was right when he said
that Trump Tower was wiretapped hey
Trump Tower was not wiretapped
that was wrong but if what Trump was
saying is my campaign was surveilled by
the FBI that obviously was true but that
doesn't answer the question as to
whether his campaign should have been
surveilled by the FBI or whether people
in his campaign should have been under
FBI investigation none of that is it
speaks to what actually happened so I
think that what we have to recognize is
that there are two ways of viewing this
investigation one is as though you were
in the shoes of the FBI as this evidence
was coming to you and one is now in
retrospect if you are viewing the
evidence as it came in it would have
been perfectly reasonable in my opinion
to say okay we need to get an informant
on what's going on here because there's
a lot of suspicious stuff going on here
and we need to check it out that
wouldn't have been unreasonable in
retrospect because they haven't been
able to dig up anything really of
substance it looks much more
unreasonable it looks like wow you
really you spent all these resources but
if we used that same logic with law
enforcement investigations all the time
then law enforcement would not be able
to do investigations because you can
only assess whether
to do an investigation based on the
evidence that is in front of you to
given time listen this is not me trying
to rip on the Trump campaign again I
don't think any collusion happened but I
want to be as intellectually honest as
possible about what's going on in this
investigation so we can actually target
the bad guys I don't think that the
people who were concerned about what
they were hearing in June 2016 were the
bad guys I think the people who are
leaking out this information knowing
there was nothing there afterward those
are the bad guys the people inside the
FBI who decided to leak to the New York
Times all this information those are the
bad guys because now they're obviously
attempting to throw president Trump
under the bus to sully his
administration they are attempting to do
that now and we obviously should look
into the cart page FISA warrant and make
sure that that was legit we obviously
should make sure that what the FBI did
was legit but I'm not seeing the
evidence that the FBI was attempting to
get Trump during the campaign they
didn't release any of this information
during the campaign they kept it on the
down-low all the way through the
campaign was only after the campaign
that they started leaking that stuff out
and I would imagine that was a lot of
frustrated pro-hillary people who are
leaking that sort of material out in the
first place
now I won't explain a little bit more
about that in just a second but first I
want to say thanks to our sponsors over
at the u.s. CCA so it's nearly in the
end of the line for this particular deal
over at the u.s. CCA look the world is a
really scary unsafe place in many ways
there are a lot of times when they're
there
rogue shooters today there's an awful
awful story about a mass shooting
happening at a Texas high school which
we'll bring to you a little bit later in
the show but that just means that is a
law-abiding citizen you should own a gun
you should only gun defend yourself and
defend the lives of others I've been
talking about this for weeks now you
have a few days left to get your dream
gun for free right now the u.s. CCA is
giving five of you my lucky listeners
$1,000 to buy your dream Kimber with
extra ammo again your law-abiding
citizen you know how to use a gun you
should own one that's great five of you
will take home $1,000 to buy one of the
finest handguns in the world it is
completely free your chances to win and
next Friday there will be no guns after
that simply go to defend my family now
calm and instantly lock in your five
free chances to win right now it's that
simple you can enter in seconds
two-hundred percent free you're almost
out of time before the u.s. CCA draws
the winners so get your name on the
winners let's now go to defend my family
now Comte answer before it's too late as
a matter of principle I believe that all
law-abiding people who know how to use a
weapon should own one because they're
bad people out there and the occa helps
make sure that that can happen for you
not only through this special deal where
you go to defend my family now calm you
have five chances to win
thousand bucks for a gun but also they
bring you all the legal help that you
need all the education on gun training
that you need you OCC it's a great
organization go to defend my family now
calm let's defend my family now calm
okay so back to Andrew McCarthy's rip on
this crossfire hurricane investigation
he says the Clinton case was a criminal
investigation that was predicated on a
mountain of incriminating evidence in
the scheme of things the the Clinton the
scandal here's that mrs. Clinton was not
charged by contrast the Trump case is a
counterintelligence investigation
unlike criminal cases
counterintelligence matters are
classified if agents had made public
disclosures about them they would have
been committing crimes and violating
solemn agreements with foreign
intelligence services agreements without
which those services would not share
information that the u.s. national
security officials need in order to
protect the country in the scheme of
things the problem is not that the FBI
honored its confidentiality
confidentiality obligations in the Trump
case while violating them in the Clinton
case the scandal is that the FBI lacking
the incriminating evidence needed to
justify opening a criminal investigation
of the Trump campaign decided to open a
counterintelligence investigation again
I think this misses the point the
question is really whether you're
allowed to have an informant on a case
whether or not there is a formal
investigation that has been filed and
I'm not seeing the evidence that that's
the case again informants come in all
shapes and sizes and I think that this
is a bit of an overreach by a lot of
folks who are hoping to sully the the
original origins of the of the
investigations that then they can make
the excuse that that the investigation
has to be shut down right now Kimberly
Strasser was doing some of the same
stuff over at the Wall Street Journal
she has a piece today where she talks
about house key Intelligence Committee
chairman Devin Nunez who appeared on Fox
and Friends where he provided a
potentially explosive hint and what's
driving his demand to see documents
related to the FBI's Trump Russia probe
said if the campaign was somehow set up
I think there'll be a problem so now I
guess the going theory here is that
Carter page and George papadopolis were
not in fact in the thrall of Russians
instead it was that the FBI and the CIA
set up a sting operation in order to
entice them to look as though they
wanted to work with the Russians so net
changes the theory of the case now the
argument is no longer there shouldn't
have been an informant after we found
out that Papadopoulos in-page were doing
stuff now the argument is that the
informant himself was the person who
sort of entrapped Carter page and and
George papadopolis I'm gonna need to see
the evidence of that I'm gonna need to
see the evidence as to what it was
is the implication here that the London
professor that George papadopolis met
with back in 2016 that that guy was
actually a FBI stooge that he was
somebody the FBI had deployed I don't
see all the evidence of this in any real
way I'm gonna wait for all the evidence
to come out maybe that happens maybe
that's the case maybe that's what
happened but I'm gonna need to see a
little bit more than has been provided
to me thus far if I'm if I'm to buy that
the FBI was setting Trump up in some way
and again if they were setting Trump up
in some way wouldn't you imagine there
would have leaped all this information a
little bit earlier it doesn't make a lot
of sense to me okay meanwhile and this
is an insane story so there's a guy
named Meek Mill I've never heard of Meek
Mill I'm sure people in this room who
are not may have heard of Meek Mill
McMillan's apparently a rapper of some
sort and Meek Mill was supposed to visit
the White House on Friday he was
supposed to be at the White House
because the White House is doing
criminal justice reform so they have a
big meeting today criminal justice
reform they're gonna talk about changing
prisons prison sentences and
rehabilitation plans this is something
that a lot of libertarians are in favor
of and they're also a lot of members of
sort of the black lives matter community
who are in favor of it I'm torn on
criminal justice reform I think that
marijuana for example should be
decriminalized but I'm not in favor of
lowering sentences and releasing
prisoners back into society more easily
I'm very much of the opinion that was
stronger prison sentences in the first
place that led to the massive decline in
crime that happened between 1994 and
2015 I think that releasing people back
onto the streets is a bad idea we've
done it here in California and it's been
a giant fail in California what you've
seen instead is a massive uptick in
crime based on the release of criminals
back into the general society so it
depends what criminal justice reform
looks like in any case there are a lot
of people who think that the criminal
justice system ought to be reformed and
the White House is among those people so
this guy Meek Mill was supposed to visit
the White House to take part in a panel
that was to include I guess Vice
President Mike Pence and Jared Kushner I
and Van Jones who is obviously very much
the left now bringing people who are
right and left black and white to talk
about these issues which is what they
should do if they're going to discuss
these issues
well Meek Mill was supposed to go and
then he bailed he bailed because
according to TMZ jay-z called him up and
convinced him otherwise so according to
bossip.com Navarro
they said that reports a release that
Meek agreed to travel to 1600
Pennsylvania Avenue to discuss prison
reform because Trump is currently
hosting a prison
summit participants in attendance are
said to include members of Congress
various activists in people who become
victims of the system but it looks like
me isn't gonna make it to the event and
it's all due to words of wisdom from hob
I guess hob is jay-z is that is that
okay mm-hmm okay TMZ reports that jay-z
called the Philadelphia native on
Thursday night and made his stance clear
meaning with Trump would be nothing but
problematic for both his image and the
cause he's fighting for apparently other
high-profile celebs and friends also
called meek and voice serious concerns
about his attendants make listen to the
advice from his peers and decided not to
attend after all okay so here's the
problem for eight years everybody in the
black lives matter movement was
suggesting the law enforcement system is
biased and that criminal justice reform
had to be pursued and now Donald Trump's
going to do that and you're not gonna go
meet with him because to meet with him
and be undermined the cause how is it
undermining the cause no Democratic
House of Representatives let's say the
Democrats were in the election in 2018
let's say that they win back the house
they probably won't win back the Senate
you think criminal justice reform is
gonna get done when Nancy Pelosi is the
head not a shot because she's gonna put
a bunch of deal killers in that bill
it's not going to happen the only way
criminal justice reform gets done with
Trump as president is right now with a
bunch of Republicans in the House and a
bunch of Republicans in the Senate and
President Trump in the White House if
you want a deal you need to talk to the
guy who's capable of making the deal it
is that simple
but jay-z doesn't want the image of a
bunch of black people meeting with Trump
because it might make Trump seem not as
racist to the press that's really what
this is about so meek gave a statement
to TMZ he said I was originally
scheduled to be part of the panel on
prison reform at the White House to help
shed light on the issues within the
system
unfortunately the focus turned to the
president and myself which concerned me
that it might take away from creating a
positive result from today's discussions
well no the whole point here was that
President Trump wanted to meet with
leaders in the black community left and
right said they could have a broad
ranging discussion and hopefully come to
some sort of consensus on the issue
there's no way to come to consensus on
the issue
if you won't attend the meeting and what
do you expect Trump to do at that point
I'm frankly I'm confused by this but
this is why the entire Kanye West saga
of the last few weeks actually matters
because when Kanye West said listen I'm
not gonna listen to you guys if I feel
like meeting with Trump on me the Trump
if I feel like wearing the Magna hat oh
where I'm Agra hat and everybody on the
Left went nuts and people inside the rap
community what crazy
Ryan Kanye is tweeting out all of the
very
sweets he was receiving in text he was
receiving from people like John Legend
and Kanye to his credit said listen I'll
say what I want that's exactly what mill
makes should have said here what he
should have said is listen this is too
important an issue for me to let
partisanship get in the way it's too
important an issue for me to solve I
don't like stuff that Trump has said
don't I'm not gonna pretend that I think
the Trump has been great on racial
issues but if I can get a win here why
wouldn't I go and help my fellow black
folks who apparently are very much
ensconced in this fight for criminal
justice reform instead Meeks said I
decided not to attend that the focus
would be solely on fixing our prison
system most importantly I remain fully
committed to improving our criminal
justice system but I'm gonna insult the
President of the United States by
pulling out of the deal because jay-z
told me to when partisanship Trump's
even the best interest that you are
apparently trying to pursue I would
suggest that you have allowed your
partisanship to blind you to the actual
facts on the ground and and that really
is too bad okay in just a second I want
to talk a little bit about the the magic
power of the President Trump has he
actually does have a magic power and I
want to talk about his magic power in
just a second first I want to say thanks
to our sponsors over at Lending Club so
Lending Club gives you access to low
rates on loans up to $40,000 for almost
any purpose right you you have a debt
problem with your credit cards and you
need a loan to help carry you through
that debt problem well that's what
Lending Club is for you need to finance
a major purchase you need to finally
make some home improvements Lending Club
is there for you it's easier than going
to a bank they offer lower rates than
high interest credit cards so go to
Lending Club com answer how much money
you need and see if you are improved in
minutes and then you can pick the offer
that's right for you the money can
actually be in your account in just a
matter of days it is indeed that simple
for more than 10 years Lending Club has
helped millions of people with over
thirty 1 billion dollars in loans so
take charge of your finances of Lending
Club all you have to do is go to Lending
Club com slash man I've checked it out
it's really easy it's really user
friendly Lending Club com /ban to check
your rate for free and this will not
impact your credit score which is pretty
awesome go let go to Lending Club com
/ban that's Lending Club com /ban and
this is going to allow you to check out
all the loans see what you want see
whether you qualify all loans are made
by web bank member FDIC Equal Housing
lender so check it out again Lending
Club com /ban you can check your rate
for free it really is a first-rate
company and their folks that you can
trust to get you a loan
you need at a rate that is not
exorbitant check it out
Lending Club comm / menus that / pens
they know that we sent you okay so
meanwhile president Trump has a magic
power his magic power is that he can get
Democrats to defend anything to defend
anyone this is his magic power all
president Trump has to do is say I like
puppies and everyone loves like puppies
are horrible and if he says I hate ms-13
people onething ms-13 yeah let's look at
the second shot ms-13 sure their slogans
actually rape steal control but let's
give him a second time in Trump doesn't
like them that means that they must be
like kind of okay kind of right so Trump
as you recall said that members of ms-13
were animals now the truth is that I'm
not a big fan of calling terrorists
animals or monsters but not because I
don't think they're animals are monsters
simply because human beings can be
animals and monsters but monsters aren't
real and treating people as animals
neglects the fact that all human beings
have a capacity for evil but that's more
of a deep gloss when Trump calls them
animals I don't have any moral objection
to it it's not like I'm oh well you know
that's really insulting to the ms-13
members who chop that guy's head off I
just feel terrible about that but people
on the Left apparently felt the
necessity to go after President Trump
before going after him US 13 so Trump as
you recall a couple of days ago he said
that ms-13 were animals and he was asked
about it again and he doubled down on it
but I'm referring and you know I'm
referring to the ms-13 gangs that are
coming in and I was talking about the
ms-13 and also if you look a little bit
further on in the tape you'll see that
so I'm actually surprised you're asking
this question because most people got it
right so when the ms-13 comes in when
the other gang members come into our
country I refer to them as animals and
guess what I always will but we're
getting them out by the thousands okay
so here is the magic of Donald Trump the
left immediately starts to defend ms-13
so here's Nancy Pelosi dentures a
movement talking all about how ms-13
everything new people I miss taking our
people to Nancy Pelosi
whatever man and so when the President
of the United States says about
undocumented immigrants these aren't
people these are animals you have to
wonder it does he not believe in the
spark of divinity
the dignity and worth of every person oh
my god these are not people these are
animals the President of the United
States they literally cut the hearts out
of living human beings and she's like do
you have the spark of divinity do they
not believe in the spark of divinity
John Legend by the way did exactly the
same thing I mean it's it's incredible
it's incredible
so John Legend started tweeting out
about all this and I'm gonna find you
the John Legend tweets because they are
astonishing it's just amazing so here so
actually before I show you the John
Legend tweet I have to show you the the
Anna Navarro tweets so Anna Navarro
right on CNN she tweets out that the
well first she says that this was Nazi
rhetoric
it was Nazi rhetoric for the President
of the United States to call ms-13
animals because Hitler also hated ms-13
or something
so here's Anna Navarro saying this and
it is a very slippery slope when you
start dehumanizing people this way it's
what the Nazis did
it's what slave owners did it's not what
Americans do what now
okay and then she tweeted out is it I
love this she tweeted out that anyone
who uses the word animals to describe
another human being is just a terrible
human being there was only one problem
Anna Navarro tweeted out that Trump and
his family were basically Adam so there
was that as well as we have that tweet I
think it might be it might be 12 I'm not
sure which one it is
in any case John Legend did the same
routine he tweeted he tweeted this ad he
said even human beings who commit
heinous acts are the same species as us
not animals so here's here's one from
from Anna Navarro she tweeted out this
is a direct quote Trump is in very bad
company Nazis referred to Jews as rats
slave owners viewed slaves as subhuman
animals okay that was from yesterday in
October of 2016 here's what she tweeted
out should Donald Trump drop out of the
race yes he should drop out of the human
race he is an animal apologies to
animals slow clap Anna Navarro I mean
just my goodness Donald Trump's magic
powers it's a it's magic it's like the
Shia LeBeouf Jeff is a magic incredible
so John Legend tweeted this out even
human beings who commit heinous acts are
the same species as us not animals I'm
in the hospital with our new son any of
these babies here could end up
committing terrible crimes in the future
it's easy once they've done so to
distance ourselves from their team
but it's much more honest and
challenging to realize that they were
all babies once and to think about what
in society they're homeless etcetera it
took them from baby to violent gang
member and then to think about
collective action we could take to
mitigate those conditions and we should
particularly interrogate the role of
American policy and helping to make
ms-13 the organization it is now
dehumanizing large groups of people as
the demagogues precursor to visiting
violence and pain upon them it makes it
easier to destroy their families and
much worse okay first of all I'm happy
to deliver violence and pain on ms-13 I
think most law-abiding people are very
happy to deliver violence and pain on
the members of ms-13 one of the worst
gangs in modern on planet Earth today
okay so there's that I also love the
idea that he goes from they're not
animals at ms-13 okay not animals these
were all babies once they're not animals
they're your fault what now what I do
it's it's it's our fault we created them
as what I do to create Mara Salvatrucha
what what did i do why was that my fault
Jim John Legend does not explain but
John Legend's last name is legend and
this means he knows what he is talking
about I do love the fact that that my
favorite thing is that he says you know
when he looks at babies in the in the in
the incubators over at the hospital when
he looks at the babies who are sleeping
right after they've he says some of
those kids could turn out to be gang
members and that's why we should treat
gang members with respect how about this
how about you rewind all those babies
like four hours like four hours where
were they then when those babies before
those babies were in the nice little
plastic things at the hospital and they
were all sitting there and cute little
rows where were they before that like
four hours ago five hours ago that's
right they were in the womb the party
that you support thought that those
babies were not worth living five hours
ago so let me get this right five
minutes for babies born not a baby and
not worth preserving and not a human an
animal a ball of cells a fetus whatever
that's the Democratic party platform
five minutes before they are born
completely worthless now human babies
beautiful wonderful fast-forward 30
years ms-13 members but those ms-13
members were once babies and so we have
to protect the ms-13 members so here's
what we have learned from the Democrats
this week Hamas innocent ms-13
used to be babies NRA members are
terrorists as debbie Wasserman Schultz
said this week and babies in the womb
not worth
detecting so there may be five so the
separation between the baby in the womb
and the maybe five hours later is
apparently a greater separation than the
separation between the baby now and the
ms-13 member thirty years later okay
like Trump's magic power is very
powerful it is very very powerful I did
to get people to say things this stupid
you have to that's that's what it has to
be he must have some he must be like
King Saul I must go visit like the
witches of Endor and he just goes out
there and visits with the witches and
then they tell him what to do I don't
know what power trump has I don't know
whether he goes out back and sacrifices
goats whatever it is he is somehow
trolled the left into being completely
insane completely insane because I don't
know how in the world you get a rational
person to say these kinds of things
it is absolutely beyond me the the
ability of Donald Trump to troll by the
way is so incredibly strong that he even
was able to get Democrats to be very
very angry over this little joke video
that he put over up over Laurel and
Yanni so I don't know if you I'm sure
you saw this whole Laurel and Yanni
thing where there's this this piece of
audio where you can either hear it as
Laurel or you can hear it is Yanni some
people hear it as laurel some people
hear it as yanny and it has to do with
the pitches that you hear if you're
higher frequencies then you tend to hear
Yanni you're lower frequencies you tend
to hear Laurel I've heard it both ways
okay so the White House cut this little
cute video of various members of the
administration who are talking about
whether it was Laurel or eonni so
clearly it's Laurel
but I could deflect and divert to Annie
if you need me to Sara it's been
reported that you here tomorrow how do
you respond
clearly you're getting your information
from CNN because that's fake news all I
hear is yawning oh man that's Laurel
Laurel who's handy I hear Kofi okay and
funny stuff look at the comments
underneath this video for president
Trump on Twitter and it's all like why
aren't you going out there and saving
babies president Trump why do you hate
children president from how could you
possibly be spending the seven minutes
it took to put together this video
president Trump not focusing on the real
issues in the world like global warming
easy guys he's made you guys crazy I'm
sorry he's made you utterly insane
because you're now defending a mess
they're like what are you doing what
continue doing it by all means by all
means if you're a Democrat and you're
listening to the sound of my voice
continue being this continue being these
people because all it's doing is helping
Republicans get elected there's a reason
Republicans are gonna retain the Senate
and gain seats in the Senate is right
now about a 50/50 shot Republicans
retain the house if you told me this
five months ago I would have thought you
were nuts given the generic ballot but I
guess that if Trump's management power
is put to good use then this is where
you end up can we're getting to the
mailbag in just a second but before that
you're gonna have to go over to Daley
wire calm so subscribe it daily we're
calm for $9.99 a month you get the rest
of this show live you also get to be
part of the mailbag also you get to do a
you also get early tickets when we have
our events right you actually got that
this week
now the tickets are open to general
admission and I guess they do in like
half an hour for our events in Dallas
and Phoenix but if you've been a
subscriber you've been able to get early
tickets which would have been better for
you because now it may be sold out so
check out our events by the way also if
you want an annual subscription you get
all of those wonderful things plus you
get this
the leftist tears hot or cold tumblr
epic masterful I mean just engraved with
the with the paint of the Gods it's it's
just it's not even it's not even paint I
mean they actually just scratch out H my
blind nuns it's just it's incredible
he's leftist here's how to call them the
mugs you check them out for the annual
subscriber fee of 99 bucks cheaper in
the monthly subscription also check out
Apple News where we have all of our
daily wired material our traffic has
been through the roof and really
appreciate everybody checking out our
news on Apple news also you just want to
watch later to listen late
go over to YouTube go over to iTunes you
can check it out for free leave us a
review we are the largest fastest core
and conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
okay so meanwhile let's go to the
mailbag let's just jump right into the
mailbag because there are a lot of good
questions all right so Carl says hey Ben
can you recommend a good book or two not
too lengthy that serves a good primer
for the history of Israel up until at
least the 2006 election in Gaza I feel
like my historical knowledge here is
lacking thanks Carl so the one that I
always recommend is there is a great
book by a guy named Mitchell bard called
myths and facts about Israel and it's
about 400 pages but it's really user
friendly because it's not you know
you're trying to swallow enormous sums
of information at a time instead it's
broken down by topic so he gives you a
myth and then gives you a fact about
Israel and it's really really useful
Joshua says hi Ben and big fans you ever
worry that your own bias clouds your
objectivity on issues for example Israel
and Palestinians thanks love the show so
sure yes yes and I think when I was
younger it certainly clouded my
objectivity on issues with regard to
this this particular issue especially
and that's why I've there are things
that I've said about this issue that I
regret obviously I mean there was a
column I wrote in 2002 I believe when I
was 19 18 years old about the about
transferring people from from Judea to
Mary on the Gaza Strip and Israel
internally outside of Israel and then
later I came out I said I thought that
column was immoral and wrong and I
should have written it I think that
objectivity look there's no question
that confirmation bias and feelings can
cloud your objectivity that said this
works both ways and this week was not
evidence of my objectivity being clouded
it was evidence of the media's
objectivity being clouded because it is
pretty obvious what was going on Hamas
was announcing it I was just thinking
Hamas at their word folks in the media
had decided that they were not going to
take Hamas at their word as I said
yesterday it was like watching it was
like watching that scene from Monty
Python and the Holy Grail or the Black
Knight is standing there and King Arthur
is swiping off his limbs and he's going
merely a flesh wound well that was the
narrative the media had this narrative
there were innocent people on the Gaza
Hamas border it was it was a bunch of
people who had nothing to do with Hamas
it was it was Israel and discriminately
shooting and then Hamas comes out and
like King Arthur they're swiping off
parts of the narrative know as a bunch
of terrorists and we decide to do that
on purpose and we hide them behind
children and 50 of the 62 people who
died were Hamas members and other three
were Islamic Jihad members the music
nope don't believe you sorry don't
believe you so who's more biased here
main for believing Hamas or the media
for ignore
both the Israelis and Hamas and coming
up with their own narrative that makes
no sense and has nothing to do at the
facts on the ground okay Carl says let's
see it did Carl Stephen says hey Ben
huge fan when do you think the Muller
investigation will end also is great
seeing your speech at Clemson back in
2016 well thank you for coming to the
speech of Clemson that was really fun as
far as when the Muller investigation is
going to end who the hell knows I mean
these investigations go on for years at
a time the Whitewater investigation
which eventually ended with the Lewinsky
stuff believe it or not the Whitewater
investigation was 6 years long it
started 1994 went all the way to 2000 I
believe the the Watergate investigation
was two and a half years long so this
thing could go on for quite a while my
guess is they're gonna try and wrap it
up by the end of this year but but again
I don't have any specialized information
to give you there Andersen's I'm a
student at SUNY Purchase which is rated
the number one liberal school in New
York State last semester I started up a
Young Republicans Club which hasn't been
very popular on campus shocker the
school is very opposed to having
conservative speakers the Dean of
education even called conservatives
heartless which means that he's
brainless so how should I go about
trying to get speakers at my school
love you I think your inspiration well
thank Sandra I appreciate it the way you
should get speakers at your school is to
ignore what the administration says to
put on an app to put in an application
the same ways everybody else and then if
they reject it on the grounds of
ideological bias then you come to yeah
young Americans foundation who I'm
working with for for our campus lectures
you go to the Alliance defending freedom
and you have them sue the school I mean
really if they are rejecting people on
the basis of the perspective they're
they're purporting to offer that is a
violation of First Amendment freedoms
you go to a public school that's illegal
hi Adam says hey Ben I appreciate what
you do for America I love to debate it's
one my favorite pastimes do you see any
value in debating politics and social
issues on social media or is it just a
waste of time it depends here's my view
on debating it depends on your audience
so there are people who you're talking
with and you're having a normal
discussion normal conversation and it's
not really a debate it's more of just a
conversation sometimes that's useful
sometimes you learn something from them
they learn something from you you have a
good interchange of ideas sometimes
you're doing it in front of an audience
and in that case it depends on what you
want the audience to learn so Sam Harris
and I had a really nice kind of
discussion / debate on religion and
freewill and all the sort of stuff on
his show he was kind of to have me on
his show we're gonna have him on the
Sunday special as well we did it up in
San Francisco's really cordial it was
really nice because that's how Sam is
when he's dealing with people who
disagree
he's cordial and he's nice now you'll
see in the thug life videos there times
when people are not quite so cordial and
not quite so nice and then my obligation
in debate is to destroy them in front of
as many people as possible really to
destroy their arguments in front of as
many human beings as possible and to do
so in as brutal of fashion as is
necessary so you have to kind of gauge
what the purpose of a given conversation
is in debate crystal says it bends you
ever wear yarmulkes in other colors
besides black are their holidays they
call for specific colors so there's
nothing religiously that says you have
to wear a yarmulke that is black or not
black there are gradations actually it's
really interesting just like in every
aspect of human life of human life once
you get into the nitty-gritty of any
particular custom it turns out there are
all sorts of gradations to the custom so
at my wedding
I wore white keepa actually then maybe
in the last time I wore white keepa
there's been discussion in the office as
to whether I should wear a yarmulke of a
different color you know it'd be like a
horse of a different color from Wizard
of Oz we just change randomly but it's
but there are gradations in the type of
people you are so I wear a knit keep up
I wear one that is knitted out of I
assume that it's wool or something and
there are also velvet keep out believe
it or not in the Orthodox community you
can tell somebody's philosophy by the
kind of people they were so if you are a
velvet keepa this tends to mean that you
are more black hat I'm being black hat
right wearing the black hat another
physical indicator is an indicator that
you are less ensconced with sort of the
modern world and more ensconced with a a
more strict interpretation of Torah I
think that would be fair to say it means
you black hat it's considered sort of
more orthodox I'm modern orthodox I go
to a black hat minion which means I
interact with people who are black hat
all the time but people divide
themselves in a bunch of ways depending
on the kind of kippa that they wear in
Israel if your keep us through gahh
right which is a knitted keepa that
means that you probably served in the
military and you're in favor of people
serving the military if you are a velvet
keepa then the chances are that you're
probably less in favor of people serving
in the military although even there
there are some soft boundaries so I know
you didn't want that level of
specificity you got it anyway
Jordan says Ben what is your opinion on
the Supreme Court's decision to allow
states to legalize sports betting
looking forward to seeing you live in
Dallas well Jordan I'm glad that you
bought a ticket I look forward to seeing
you there too as well and everybody
should buy a ticket it's gonna be a
blast my opinion on the Supreme Court
decision is that states of course should
be able to decide whatever they want on
sports betting I don't know what the
hell the federal government has to do
with sports betting
I don't think the federal government
should have anything to do with sports
betting I don't think the federal
government should have anything to do
with sports I don't think the federal
with nearly anything so I'm wondering
where in the Constitution it says that
we're an article 1 of the Constitution
it says the legislature gets to
determine the levels of betting
federally within States it makes no
sense at all so that is the correct
decision indeed and as far as the
argument that is then made well then
DiPietro's do something wrong yes he did
he was a coach at the time it's not the
same thing okay if I bet on sports it's
not the same thing as if I'm playing in
the game and betting on myself for
betting on somebody else Christian says
hey Ben you have any comments on the
political status of Puerto Rico could
they ever become a state what could be
the pros and cons of making Puerto Rico
state well the big Pro the big con right
now is that Puerto Rico has significant
levels of debt that would have to be as
apparent Lee assume by the federal
government if Puerto Rico were to be
made into a state I'm not averse to
making Puerto Rico a state I think
there's been a lot of discussion and
Marco Rubio I think is in favor of
making Puerto Rico a state it's always
sort of a political football because
there's a lot of people who think that
if you make Puerto Rico a state and
people can suddenly their votes counts
in presidential elections that this
changes the nature of politics in the
United States I don't see a huge
obstacle to making Puerto Rico a state
other than the problem of they've been
running not as a state for a very long
time which means they've run up a
significant amount of debt and they've
been pretty poorly governed Joseph says
hey Ben our son just made the cutoff
tense for kindergarten next year my wife
is dead set on holding him back she's
fearful we'll be putting him in a
disadvantage down the line due to this
being the trend in New Jersey assuming
he's ready do you think it could be more
damaging to send him as the youngest kid
in the grade or to hold him back which
could lead him not having to work as
hard down the line thanks and love the
show Joe so Joe um you know I I have a
sort of weird story on this so when I
was a kid I was the oldest in my class
my parents sort of held me back I was
born in January with my birthday's
January 15th
send me flowers so my birthday was
January that meant that I was the oldest
kid in my class when I started I skipped
third I skipped nine so I skipped a
couple of grades so by the time I was
done I was definitely the youngest kid
in my class by a fair bet
yeah I think that people seat their own
level I don't think that whether you
enter fifth grade as a as a very old
five year old or enter fifth grade as a
very young five year old is gonna make
any significant difference in the realm
of life and if your son's a high
achiever his aging to make the
difference so I don't think it makes a
huge difference I would tend toward the
idea where we're have
make this decision right now actually
with my daughter I would tend toward the
idea of putting your kid in school early
if they if it means they're more
challenged I think challenging kids is
good and I think that a lot of the fears
about oh they're gonna be the youngest
kid in the class and be bullied at five
that's not really a concern at ten
that's a concern ten-year-old kids are
just terrors paying ones once once kids
hit like seven eight nine and basically
between the time they're seven and the
time they're 17 kids are just very very
difficult to mandi things but when
they're five I don't think it's gonna
make much of a difference Nicholas says
what do you think are the most important
issues that the United States faces in
both foreign and domestic policy I have
no answer this listen to the show I mean
that's like that's literally my answer
like then that is the broadest question
I have ever heard in my entire life so
no answer Gerald says hey man why didn't
previous presidents keep their promise
and move the US Embassy from Tel Aviv to
Jerusalem so the reason they didn't move
the US Embassy from Tel Aviv to
Jerusalem is they were ensconce in a
foreign policy establishment that lied
to them and that told them that if they
did so it would create a conflict ratio
in the Middle East
massive Wars would break out everyone
was gonna die okay that wasn't true okay
the the basis for that was that there
was an inter FATA meaning an uprising
violent terrorist uprising in 2001 when
Ariel Sharon who was almost Prime
Minister of Israel who was elected very
shortly thereafter went up on the Temple
Mount
I was actually 2000 went up on the
Temple Mount and there was a riot that
turned into a quasi war in the Middle
East and so the idea was if we moved the
embassy than we were creating all sorts
of chaos to be fair to those other
presidents the situation on the ground
is not quite the same as the situation
is now thanks to President Obama making
nice with Iran that has pushed all of
these other countries into a position
where they have to ally with Israel in
order to counter Iran so is it possible
that if the embassy had been moved 20
years ago there would have been actual
activity on the Arab Street sure is it
also possible that nothing would have
happened sure but bottom line is I think
it should been done for moral reasons
regardless because failing to recognize
truth I think is generally a large
mistake Noah says hey Ben I'm a huge fan
of yours I may disagree with you on some
things but I appreciate how
intellectually honest your approach is I
also take your opinion on Family Values
to heart but that being said that has
been troubling me being troubling me I'd
love to hear your thoughts on I used to
be an atheist now I'm more of an
agnostic Diaz but my values fall
strongly in line with Jewish Christian
teachings this makes dating difficult
since most people who are non-christians
tend to have liberal values so naturally
I am interested
dating a Christian but few Christians
want to be unevenly yoked with a
non-christian I remember what you said
about pursuing relationships with people
who share your values in reference to I
interfaith relationships don't typically
work but how would you work that for
some of them like me I really do want to
have a family one day but don't
realistically ever see myself becoming a
Christian do you have any advice well
first of all I think there are a lot of
people who are like you know I don't
think that I think there are a fair
number of people who listen to me listen
to Jordan Peterson listen to people who
believe in the value of the
judeo-christian heritage but aren't
necessarily totally on board with the
miraculous events surrounding Jesus or
the miraculous events surrounding Sinai
for example that said I think the big
question when it comes to your religious
beliefs is how are you going to raise
your kids how are you gonna raise your
kids it is very difficult to raise your
kids outside of a religious system
religious systems work they allow your
kid to believe in something that is more
important and something higher and allow
your child to identify a narrative that
makes that story true this is why if
you're dating a Christian you said
listen I have my personal struggles with
believing in the divinity of Jesus
Christ for example but when it comes to
our children I want our kids to learn
about the divinity of Jesus Christ
because I believe that that divinity is
important to understanding the
developments of the Western world and
the set of judeo-christian values and
then when they become an adult they can
make a decision about what they actually
want to believe I think there are a lot
of Christians who might be interested in
talking about that Plus you may you
never know you may start going to church
and you may start to believe in the
miraculous you may start to believe that
it is possible that God actually whether
it's Sinai or whether through Jesus
brought a certain system of morality to
the world through interaction with the
world you never know how your beliefs
are going to change but being honest and
open about the person you're dating
about where you stand I think is key
number one key number two is recognizing
how you're gonna raise your kids because
when I say the values matter it doesn't
just matter between you and your wife
and matters between how you and your
wife are going to deal with your child
so and bottom line is if you're trying
to date people who are not comfortable
with you it's not gonna be a comfortable
dating or marriage experience anyway but
I do think there are people out there
who believe what you believe and are
gonna respect that perspective okay so
should we do things I like and things I
hate I think that I wouldn't even have
any things I like are things I hate
today you know what everything is fine
everything is okay you know we're just
gonna we're just gonna we're just gonna
go into the weekend enjoy ourselves we
will be back here on Monday we'll have
all the latest for you then I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing